unfortunately at schools you're required
to learn whatever they teach you and
then
you know write a test on it or uh you
know do exercise on it all of which i
find
unpleasant and unhelpful hi there
steve kaufman here today i want to talk
about you know should you go to a
language school
to learn a language
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe you can click on the bell for
notification
all right so the overwhelming majority
of people who study languages who learn
languages
do so i think
at schools
uh here in vancouver we have all kinds
of schools downtown and elsewhere where
people come to learn english
people go to spain to learn spanish
people go to china to learn chinese and
so forth
and of course there are schools
here say in vancouver that teach
french or arabic or whatever these can
range from universities to
all kinds of language schools
how can we use these schools how
beneficial are they
all right this depends entirely on your
own
preference like so much in language
learning personally i would not attend a
language school
and i'll explain why
what the language school provides is
instruction in the language in other
words
explanations of how the language works
the language school provides the
materials the textbooks
the content from which we learn
the language schools can provide
encourage encouragement motivation
the language school provides a social
context where you meet not only your
teacher but other students
the language school can keep you going
so it is possible that for many people a
language school is an ideal learning
environment
why is that not the case for me
because
insofar as explanations of how the
language works
that is available everywhere i can
google
for grammars in romanian arabic
turkish any language i want
i can buy a small grammar book
occasionally leaf through it i don't
have to learn
the structures and the rules of grammar
uh on whatever order the teacher decides
for me i can learn these and look these
things up and access the grammar
whenever i want to on my own schedule on
my own so i have no need for a teacher
to take me through the explanation of
the grammar and how the language works
also as many of you know if you've been
listening to me i believe that the the
introduction of grammar
it's not something that you can get up
front that explains the the language to
you and then you can proceed and learn
the language rather it's a matter of
getting a lot of the language in you
listening reading using link if you're
using link
and then
looking up
items of grammar whenever you want so
you might have an initial overview
forget most of the rules that you saw
there and then go back time and time
again on your own schedule
to refer back to explanations of how the
language works when you are curious
about something
unfortunately at schools you're required
to learn whatever they teach you and
then you know write a test on it or
you know do exercise on it all of which
i find
unpleasant and unhelpful
when it comes to the context the content
the materials again
the range of language content that's
available on the internet is far far
greater
than what the teacher can provide you in
fact the best teachers
will direct you to resources on the
internet uh whether it be beginner
material or at the other end you know
movies from netflix and so forth in the
language that you are learning so i have
no need for a school to provide the sort
of learning content that i
need
i'll go and find that on my own and and
but it may well be that a person who's
not as well organized in in finding this
kind of content
would benefit from being at a school
where there is more discipline
now of course you don't have to go to a
school you can have an online tutor such
as i have for persian and that person or
arabic or other languages and that
person can often be very helpful in
finding or even creating as is the case
with my persian tutor
content
so the school can be a source of content
but that's not the only source of
content
the school
provides a social context you meet other
learners
that has its pluses and minuses if
you're in a classroom with 10 other
people
some people will be
better than you some people will not be
as good
um
it can sometimes for some people
it can be motivate motivating that some
people are better than them other people
may be discouraged by the fact that
other people are better than them
also listening to people who speak with
a heavy accent or who have trouble
speaking and having to listen through
that in a classroom is not something
that i enjoy i would far rather just
listen to a native speaker
who you know even if i'm listening on my
airpods or listening in a movie in other
words i can achieve
a more sort of
native language listening and reading
context
which is better for me than sitting in a
classroom listening to other people
answer questions or interact with each
other or with the teacher so
now granted you make friends in the
classroom and that's a major motivation
that can be good it can be bad
if i see the students in downtown
vancouver who are learning english i
find the brazilians get together with
each other the mexicans get together
with each other the koreans get together
with each other so my question is are
they in fact
using this sort of social
connection opportunities of a language
class
in order to
practice their language and learn the
target language
or are they socializing with people from
the same background
the more time you spend with the
language that you're learning the better
you will do so if you end up spending
time
talking to people in your own language
that is time that's taken away from
you know learning the language
so
other disadvantages are of the school
might be that you have to travel to the
school now
it can be if you're traveling to
salamanca spain in order to work on your
spanish or you're going to guanajuato to
work on your spanish or you're going to
prog to work on your check then the fact
of being in the country in a place where
the language is spoken is a great reason
to go to a school
however again are you better off sitting
in a classroom in guanajuato or
salamanca or prague
or being out in
the city interacting with people now
it's often difficult you can't just
arrive in guanajuato and
randomly talk to people so to that
extent the school provides you with a
ready-made
group of people the teachers who are
sympathetic to you who are going to talk
to you in spanish and so all of that is
good so that again is
so the the secret to making the most of
your experience at a language school is
go to where the language is spoken speak
to your teachers by all means
try to find people outside the classroom
and spend as little time as possible
with people of the same background as
you who are learning the target language
of course the issue with with language
schools is the cost so there again you
have to look at your own learning style
how made how motivated are you you know
intrinsically by yourself to what extent
do you need the motivation and the
discipline and the sympathetic ear of
the teachers at the school
versus how capable are you of finding
material on your own finding people to
talk to on your own
so i think
one can't it's not a situation where one
answer is sort of one one solution works
for everyone i think it's for everyone
to decide
how they like to learn
how they like to spend their time
and so while personally i wouldn't go to
a language school because i would feel
that it sort of imposes uh
constraints on my language on my on my
language learning and it's it's an
expense that i would rather forego do
without
but i think uh many people if as long as
they do enough on their own outside of
the classroom they can make a success
of learning in the classroom
and probably the success rate
is greater amongst students who go to
classrooms
because maybe most people aren't as
motivated
as i am to be perfectly honest but i
think it's still up to each person to
decide for himself or herself
thank you for listening
and i hope you make the right decision
for yourself when it comes to language